[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
what's going on guys man i'm pretty sure
everyone can hear me uh
it's been good day man we're back
another week with the attic show got a
special guest man got fonzarelli what's
going on fox what have you been playing
man well you know we were just talking
about eldon ring um it's funny i beat
the game after seven days 44 hours but i
jump back in because uh i can't get into
another game i don't want to bring it up
again because i keep bringing it up but
there's another game on the playstation
side i've been trying to get through
that i'm having a hard time with and i
can't get back into it like especially
after eldon ring so are you saying that
horizon forbidden west got uh breath of
the wild
just like the original one yeah i got
breath of the wild did for sure and i'm
also saying that it's just it's not a
game of the year contender in my opinion
it's just not
it's just not
that's going to start a lot of a lot of
little things i've gotten a lot of hate
for saying that but i'm sorry
has the personality of a slug all right
a slug you're giving me
i i feel like we could give her the
personality in all the object because
she she's like a rock she don't really
make any you know we're going to move
past that we're going to move past that
you know you know
you know the little water stain you
might have on your uh on your table or
something yeah that has more personality
than eloy hey that's why they're being
on your is man i ain't saying nothing
about a lloyd i don't want no smoke
terrible protagonist man look great
combat skills but terrible protagonists
when it comes to the dialogue and stuff
i just i don't i can't feel her you know
like just she's not for me man like i
try to play the game
and she's kind of borderline annoying
and just
yeah it's it's not it's not that fun to
me uh the combat's cool but other than
that the dialogue and stuff is just way
too laborious like there is so much
dialogue in this game uh man
too much sometimes there is too much
dialogue in the game and there is yeah
i i i was feeling that you know
uh sorry to like well you know i don't
care i'm not apologizing to the chat for
me derailing the conversation it's my
podcast i'll derail if i want to but uh
i was playing um strategy triangle
strategy for the nintendo switch and
there's a lot of dialogue in that too
and i feel like it is borderline too
much and
it it goes into that thing where it's
like if i'm doing more talking than i'm
doing playing the game we got an issue
sure i feel like the rest of the game
still
cleared that bar to me
but you know triangle strategy was one
of those games that
it it has a lot going for it but the
stuff it doesn't have going for really
hurts it so we got a two dollar super
trap from flame
more like horizon forbidden 90s my uh
meta a marath am i right guys
oh man that's good
you look great you're right look and
then we got a two-dollar superstar from
drawing tj
hi guys what's going on man it's all
right all right what up tj what are you
doing hustle well i see you got the the
the iop logo on
oh i i'm one thousand percent do sir
product placement kinds of products
project placement yeah um
i was doing some stuff you know with the
setup that i know i know i know i see
the rgb lights in the background my
little mario thing is right there oh my
god man yeah yeah i want to kind of make
this more like home i'm sure actually
sharing this open space with my pops so
his stuff would go there and i kind of
want to make this as you know as
streamer friendly as possible um
what i've been playing uh we was talking
about it before but i beat uh margeet
who
whose name i spelled wrong and
pronounced strong anyway
i got that old buddy me and the mpc um
i'm the prisoner in the class and i
don't give a damn what nobody say i beat
them on my own and i handle help from
nobody
especially the trouble shooters
no um i actually streamed it on sunday
you know i plan on uploading the
like the boss fight that i want i plan
on uploading that if not tomorrow the
day after
i've just been kind of caught up doing a
lot of things but um
yeah i've been having fun um played
aladdin again been playing animaniacs
and um
i'm starting to play through on super
mario rpg what day is it there's a
wednesday probably friday i will
probably start that friday
that's what's up all right so this is
this is what we're going to do all right
because i i do want a little bit of
feedback real quick on uh
the the attic show stuff that uh i'm
about to start doing all right so i am
in the process of getting this took care
of when it comes to
what the show is going to look like how
it's going to look like uh fonz i sent
you a screenshot of um on twitter so uh
let me bring it up real quick and i'm
going to show you guys
exactly what i got in mind i'm not
showing you all of it uh because i feel
like there's got to be there's got to be
some kind of uh you know
what's going on they got to be a little
bit of surprise man just gotta be that
element of surprise you gotta you gotta
give them just a little get them excited
and then you know
all right so
let me it's always fun yeah and it's
just like
this is one of those things where
i don't want to do this twice so i i'm
taking my time
dotting all my teas man because
i ain't looking to do this again i'm
just not the addict etiquette you get
that ready uh mom's already tell the
great people where they can find you um
every tuesday night and tell the people
where they can conjure up yeah tuesday
night's
rdx podcast which is uh dealer gaming in
the crew on dealer gaming's channel you
can find me there every tuesday night 5
p.m yeah what's funny is someone in the
chat said today you have a good uh
a good take i guess people ain't like
some of the takes you'd be having
you know what
that's how i am and i'm an honest person
honest gamer when it comes down to these
games if i don't like something i'm
going to tell you i don't like it yeah
and why and i think people know i have
no problem with that people need to stop
with this everyone has to have the same
mentality stuff because i feel like it
it's it's too it's too much
uh of course you can find me fonzeroli
gaming on my channel here on youtube and
of course i do my podcast every sunday i
do games talk live where i go one on one
with a guest usually sometimes it's one
on two but that's rare it's usually one
on one and i have a good time doing that
so check me out 2 p.m sundays
so let me go and switch this all right
so let me switch this transaction all
right so
this is what it's going to look like all
right so here's here's the first one
guys here's the first one now as you
guys could see i want i want something a
little simplistic man a little
simplistic the the goal here is just me
and hustle i'm gonna have an iop crest
in the middle everything's gonna be
animated i'm gonna have our twitter
handles at the bottom
that's what this one's gonna go with it
and i think that's pretty
self-explanatory at that point uh i i
don't want anything like
i don't want any attention took away
from us talking like i don't want like
crazy animation avatars in the left or
right like it looks cool but i do think
it takes away from the point of the show
uh but you know there is one thing that
i really debated on doing and that was
like
any form of like making things different
if i have like a guest or something
uh so i went ahead and decided to do the
guest thing now what this one is is it's
pretty much a guest loan now i want the
guests screen to be bigger
than us like not much but you know i
want the focus of the show to be on the
guests like because i do plan on doing
more
uh you know going to packs next month so
i'm gonna try to get as many developer
interviews set up as possible so that's
really why i made something like this
and obviously i got a little bit more
set up but you know this is pretty much
what i'm looking at right now guys uh
you know i promise you i got some stuff
cooking man it's gonna take a little
time because anyone that does art you
guys know the thing
it's very time consuming
all right so
let's go ahead let's get these super
chats real quick you guys are really
showing up today with these super chats
we got a two dollar super chat for lord
metro good to see fawns back yes eldon
ring is game of the year i won't go out
and say it's game of the year yet i want
so far
i won't go that far because i got to see
now i got to see how harry potter is and
i got to see how starfield is but i will
say
that man the the they got they got a
fight like they got a serious fight like
this is like one of those scenarios
where it's like goku vs jared and he's
about to go ultra instinct is goku will
get that ultra instinct before he gets
thrown out of the map
really quick you're frozen my friend oh
i'm frozen of course i'm frozen
you know what's funny uh when i was
going into this year to 2022 uh i
already had it in my mind that number
one star field would be a game of the
year contender for sure for sure because
i mean given the pedigree of bethesda
and their single-player rpgs that they
bring out
let's be real i mean they've already
like the
what was it before 76 the past four so
games were game of the year contenders
they've had four game of the year award
winners and that's going back to
oblivion skyrim
uh i think fallout 3 and fallout 4. all
game of the year awards hold on hold on
that game comes out 11 11
of this year right same as skyrim yeah
no no no no i'm cool and i'm i'm cool
with the whole legacy yeah you know
doing that whole thing but i think the
development developer i think the people
who are on the board when they need time
to actually like sit down playing whoa
wasn't that
hopefully with any luck it won't be like
that hopefully they'll get plenty of
time to actually sit down and play that
like i don't know exactly how they're
going to do it most of the time you know
these big open rpgs like that you get
weeks ahead of time to play it it just
depends on this game seems like like the
way it's been described to me this game
is pretty much done they're just making
sure it's all about optimization they
want this to shine on the xbox series
accent i personally feel like this game
was probably set for last year but
microsoft since they bought bethesda
they might have pushed it into this year
just to give them because they don't
want buckfest anywhere in these titles
and they don't want none of that man you
can't have a bethesda game without some
bugs that that's going to be there you
might have you know an ox on the roof of
your house or whatever an alien on the
roof stuck
crap like that happens but
my whole point of bringing that up was
is that i already thought okay that's
game of the year contender and it still
is in my mind however that's the one i
was pushing to probably take it this
year until i played elden ring and then
i played elden ring and it blew my mind
with the world building and stuff and
i'm just like wow the from software just
put everybody on notice
and it's crazy how good the game is
because now starfield's gonna have to do
a lot more a lot better to get me to
give that the game of the year nod uh
hogwarts the thing i have against
hogwarts is well i'm kind of biased i'm
not a big harry potter fan
the game looks fantastic but
it is a big franchise that they are
turning into a video game and nine times
out of ten big franchise turns into
video games aren't very good so i feel
like this i don't know we'll see i feel
like this might be the exception because
it doesn't look like it doesn't look
like they're trying normally the time
when you get these these type of games
they're trying to
to push it out for a movie like crowd
across promotion
but true it doesn't look like that is
the the the cadence here it looks like
this game is standing on its own merits
with an original story original uh you
know dialogue we'll have to see how it
goes and people in the chat clouding me
for my you know scene look i'm not
saying that this game has a chance of
winning game of the year all i'm saying
is i wouldn't be surprised if it comes
out the quality it is that it could be a
contender for game of the year here's
the thing elder green's amazing it is
but at the end of the day i will say it
is the game that made it mainstream but
it's not
it's not like
it's mainstream but it's not out there
mainstream it's not like out of video
games may stream uh you know i feel like
that's a safe thing to say because
it i disagree i disagree with that and
i'll tell you why the game that made the
souls genre mainstream as you put it
that's a blub one i ain't never seen so
many people play bloodborne no this is
elden reigns on ps4
it's going i know i know it's going and
it's doing well but i feel like that was
like the start of like everything
because like here ps4 did what he did
bloodborne is kind of revealed now
here's the thing that i i will say i
will get to the superchats here in a
minute guys when it comes to
eldon ring it's a fantastic game but a
lot of people are going to be up and
down because remember a lot of the
people that vote on these games for game
of the year they're gamers but they're
not gamers like that you know what i'm
saying i don't know if all of them are
going to be playing out in the ring like
that but
the thing that harry potter has going
for is harry potter's such a well-known
name outside of gaming so even if if
it's a solid product it does exactly
what they say it does you're gonna
they're gonna have that going for them
and keep in mind i'm sure a lot of
people in
that's gonna be streaming they probably
wouldn't watch those harry potters a lot
of them probably grew up with the harry
potter franchise it's just if they
deliver now i'm not saying they could
only just deliver they got to deliver
before i would even consider it it just
to me right now it's between
star-filled
and it's between harry potter and eldon
ring and i'll give it like
eldon rings up here
star feels like right here right now and
harry potter is like right here like and
it could fluctuate depending on like the
reason eldon ring is so high is because
it's a proven product we have the final
product addict i wouldn't i i wouldn't
call it harry potter because i got
you know a lot of flack for saying that
call it hogwarts legacy because people
are almost harry potter's not in it stop
talking about harry it's like okay but
it's within the world you know whatever
it's hogwarts legacy
but again i i still maintain that you
know somebody brought up batman and the
arkham games and stuff and those are the
exception when it comes to big
franchises doing well in the video yeah
i mean for every one i mean look at
avengers
that was terrible for everyone
for every one comic book game we can
give you that was successful i can give
you four other that was trash
so
it just when it comes to those it just
depends on who was pushing it what
studio made it and what was the purpose
of making the game now if they were
making a game to be a game and not to be
a cross promotion with a movie got a
little bit better chance if you got it
if you got a studio like insomniac bacon
you got even a better chance of doing
something um indeed
i will say that this studio is kind of
unproven that's making uh
uh hogwarts legacy so you don't have to
see about that uh but eldon ring is just
elder ring is the kind of product that
we don't get very often
it's a phenomenon yeah and
it's gonna be interesting to see if
starfield could pull off being two of
them in one year because that that's
unheard of i can't i can like
i mean even fall at four wasn't like
phenomenal no uh
do you know what this it reminds me of
when i started playing elden ring and
really getting into it i was like man
i'm getting the vibes that i did when i
played skyrim for the first time
so that's kind of the phenomenon we're
dealing with here and matter of fact
it's even outpacing the sales for skyrim
it's it's crazy what what what's oh it's
it's it's gonna out it's gonna sell
skyrim i can almost get it
right
now like no no it said like 12 million i
think it's not like we'll see
the reason it's going to outsolve skyrim
is because
skyrim back then
on the 360. it was before the ps4
mainstream thing where they pushed all
the people on fortnite
it's before the war zone the battle
royale general
thing in general uh you know
i would say gamer's probably four or
five times as high as it was back then
it just we don't get the kind of quality
games i'm willing to say that we don't
get the type of quality games that we
got in the 360 generation like
let me get these super chats real quick
before they start disappearing we got a
two dog shoe drum from drawn tj you are
awesome fawns great to have you back
then we got five dollars to switch out
from dollar to taku there's only two
types of fake uh types to take
my takes and bad takes breath of the
wild i love that the lord of the rings
trilogy is a five out of ten i don't
know about that fam we're going to keep
going two dollars from drawn tj
addicts frozen i i appreciate it man i
fixed it man am i am i still good
am i frozen anymore
you're fine we're gonna get five dollars
from dawn otaku has wb made a game based
on a major franchise since batman arkham
uh they they are making a couple now
we'll just have to see how they you know
they actually come out then we got a two
dollar scripture from dawn john tj i've
never played dark souls love eldon ring
and you know we could i don't want to
talk about odin ring too long but we'll
go into it a little bit all right i
think the reason this game is being so
more welcome
is because
in the older dark souls
there were scenarios where it was
semi-open but it wasn't this open
so
dark souls one yeah you know for the
most part if you got any of the old dark
souls maybe sakura and dark souls 2 to a
point maybe even a little dark souls 3
but you got stuck
you could do something else find
something else to do with an elder and
right
and those older games like for the most
part if you get stuck
you're going turning right around and
grinding that's all you could really do
now there are some that's like i said
it's a little open you know some let you
go the direction you want to in some
form or fashion but it all leads back to
that boss
it but on this game you know if you go
left you can go right you can go up you
go down you can fight bosses you ain't
supposed to you can get one hit one hit
killed by people you ain't supposed to
it like yeah it lets you it just the
horse
exploration itself gives people the
illusion that they're not in a dark
souls game so it's more approachable
yeah everybody
and and i will go on record as saying
you know all these people complaining
about how it needs an easy mode i
disagree with them completely only
because to me the open world
and let's face it the fact that you
could summon
uh you know different ashes to to fight
alongside with you those are the easy
modes with yeah i'm about to say that
and because i mean when you could summon
yourself a second character that fights
just like you
man he takes all the aggro and you could
just go to the back of the boss and just
wail on him i just got him i literally
just got that it's just so crazy you
know and you put you nailed it uh that
is why um addict that this game is such
a phenomenon is because
when you come up against like say
margaret the first boss maybe you get
your ass handed to you you decide okay
wait a minute i'm gonna go explore go
get tougher come back and i'ma whoop
your you know what and and you do that
and and that's what makes the game so
fun because as you're exploring you're
finding other bosses other world bosses
and such that you can handle and and
that is uh the key part of this game too
where unlike most other souls games you
only have a certain number of bosses you
know to fight this one has so many that
you'll come across them that you can
handle that it's like okay i just felt
good about beating this boss maybe i
could take on that other boss now you
know
and that's it gives you that sense of
like hey i'm getting stronger i'm
getting better
and i love that feeling in this game so
let's
let's talk a little bit about
hogwarts legacy all right so
clearly i'm assuming all of us seen the
gameplay trailer now when you're looking
at this first off i want to ask you guys
is
they were very open now normally in my
experience you know tell me if i'm
bugging or not but normally in my
experience when people have that gta 5
type of demonstration where they go very
in detail on what you can do what the
point of the game is i feel like if
you're being that transparent
you know you have a hit and a re another
reason why i feel like they might have
something obviously they think they have
something obviou when we get it we can
think it's trash but you know
playstation chose to do an entire state
of play on this game
that's they don't do that often if it's
not an exclusive or a second party
exclusive you're not getting an entire
30 minutes
dedication on playstation's youtube
channel but they gave that to
the hogwarts legacy so like that's what
i want to ask you guys do you guys think
that because of the transparency and the
confidence they have in this game and
the fact that playstation is riding
dying for this game do you think that
there's a good chance that what they're
showing us is going to be a
representation of the actual game
i'll let you go because but i'm going to
tell you i'm a great
addict that's it's a great point you
bring up because how many times have we
seen sony really do a deep dive like
this on a state of play you know with a
game that was trash i don't think i've
ever seen that
so
um i i definitely think that it's going
to be representative of what they showed
um even though i'm not a fan of the you
know harry potter universe or hogwarts
universe and i don't personally like the
pew pew wand sort of
mechanics i wish they would have been
more
i wish they would have been like a
little bit more melee builds i i know
that people was like that's not harry
potter this is this isn't
they couldn't even yeah but even my
biases aside i still look at the game
and can appreciate hey it looks
fantastic it looks great it's got a lot
going for it it looks huge it looks
massive they've got a lot of rpg
elements within
uh it's definitely
representative of what we're gonna get
and and i think a lot of harry potter
fans are gonna love this game
man that joint looked mid man
because you because you're a different
npc all together i don't know if i think
you can make your own character yeah you
can cool all right that that's cool but
you come in as a fifth year student so
like you're not even going you probably
won't see like any of the main
characters or if you might see a
sprinkle here and a sprinkle there of
some of the ones that you liked and
hated listen man i'm gonna keep a trail
with you
i cut that joint off halfway through man
oh
that's because of my bias against the
whole harry potter universe all right
man let's break down the mind hustle
let's break down the mind hustle
what's the last thing you remember in
this
game play before you was like i'm done
i'm out what was the last thing that was
sho cuz i gotta know
what was shown on that screen that was
the straw that broke the camel's back
and you got up out of there like when
you had it
yeah and i'm sitting in here i'm
watching it man it was saturday saturday
afternoon i'm sitting here watching it
it was something to the effect of i
don't know a woman was talking
and i said nah i'm cool i'm cool because
i've never really been a harry potter
fan anyway but she was talking about
something and i don't know if it was
important
i said now i'm out i said i'm straight i
just cut the joint off i just wasn't i
wasn't feeling it i i got some of the
information away like you like i said
you're a fifth year student
um
you
they show like a tutorial like a
tutorial boss fight that you you have
yeah and
i guess one of the
headmasters i'm not sure what the hell
they called up in that universe one of
the teachers came and broke it up said
um
pardon me since you're not doing this on
my time do this on your own time and all
that i said all right
i said i'm good i'm good
and that agnos like and and chad knows
too like i'm a fan of like third person
stuff
i don't i don't ever like i prefer third
person over first person even that
couldn't keep me interesting man like
i'm i'm good yeah me too me too third
person over first but however i gotta
ask addict a question about this because
it
it it kind of uh
it it's odd to me that on one hand you
say that this could be a game of the
year contender but then you say the
combat could use a little work that you
think it could have a little bit more
melee
i mean because that's the thing that me
and uh it sounds like hustle had a
problem with too is the combat doesn't
look all that fun to us but to a harry
potter fan i think you know it would but
well to me i always like up in close
personal combat so that's me being a
little biased on that yeah now
as far as like how they have you handle
certain things where you can throw fire
at people and you can levitate and throw
stuff like it's got a lot of variety in
combat it looks like but it's just like
i get it in the realm of harry potter
there's not a lot of things that go
around with you know
up close combat because they're casting
spells and stuff but
one yeah it's just like
this is a game that's tooking place
before the harry potter actual franchise
so to me
they could make it lore wise where you
have melee spells maybe a couple not a
lot uh that let you get up close and
then they they in the lore of harry
potter at the end of that movie at the
end of that game they could ban them and
that's the reason they're not in the
rest of the you know that's probably the
re at the end of the day that's probably
the reason that they're not in there
because to a point they're going to be
strict on what they can do with those
type of spells but they cannot do so if
they start casting spells where they
where they're summoning shields and
swords or whatever obviously i'm not
saying to put shields and swords in the
game uh then the
the hardcore audience is gonna be like
yo
why was none of that in harry potter
like
so i i i get it but you know there is a
sword in uh there is a sword that he
that he uh he killed the snake with the
sword of gryffindor or whatever the hell
that thing's called so i can
i can understand to a point
where
they were in terms of the lord but it's
just like
put the son of gryffindor's in a k like
i just i feel like if you do nothing but
long-range weapons
there's not a lot of games that are only
good for gun play like though the reason
i didn't like
horizon is because i don't like bow
combat at all like it's one of the most
dead things i've ever done in a game a
bull comic
like
and i get it it's a variety of combat
it's not just a bow you know they got uh
you know she's got critical hits that
she does on the bosses it actually makes
sense to the world of horizon but
regardless i didn't care because i
didn't like her as a character and i
didn't like the combat and i think the
thing that makes this a little bit
different
is
you're actually going to school and you
can learn your arsenal and you can make
your person the way you want them to be
so just because there's not like some
kind of melee attacks i'm assuming
you're going to be able to go you could
learn the dark arts if you want to
because it seemed like it like it said i
said at the beginning you could control
dark arts it to a point like in some way
so i'm assuming you could do that at a
point it said you could learn against
the dark arts maybe you can actually
maybe it's got multiple ranching paths
where you could be good bad or like
neutral or just have a couple endeavor
things so there's a lot of pers
there's a lot of
opportunity in this game it's just
regardless what we see regardless what
they tell us none of that matters that
they don't execute it you know they yeah
you know it's funny geek in the chat he
said y'all don't know nothing about
harry potter you know what i'll admit i
don't uh the only
extent i have to any type of lore with
harry potter at all is two movies i've
watched and i was bored to tears on i i
can't i just didn't like the harry
potter stuff
so yeah i don't know much about the the
world of harry potter i do know they use
wands and stuff so i get it for this
game but for me that
it doesn't interest me to play the game
however again i will maintain it looks
really good for what it is it's well
polished it looks awesome the graphics
and for a harry potter fan
i'm sure it's amazing to you guys
so
yeah it's just like
i hope it's good man i'm really feeling
what i see it's just i got to see the
actual i got to see the end goal i got
to see how big this world is it seemed
like it's a massive world you go to
multiple different places but i got to
see exactly how it's done and you know i
don't think there's too much to talk
about when it comes to hogwarts legacy
we'll have to uh you know kind of we'll
probably talk more about this when we
get more information
but the amount of information they gave
us i really doubt we're going to get
something like that again we're probably
just going to see the game
we might get i don't think any one of us
here even you know hustle none of us
wish ill will on this game we you know
we always want to see games succeed um
so regardless of our biases or whatnot
we want to see the game do well um and
i'm i'm all for it being a game of the
year contender the more the better man
hell i love to see great games being
released yeah i mean i'm buying it day
one because it looks interesting but
uh i'm not saying that they need assault
rifles i'm not saying they need swords
like what's crazy they do but that's
just me you know what what what's crazy
take an rpg in it you know
imagine if you like you like just blast
you make an rpg and you shoot you know
that's going to be done on pc they're
going to do something in there some
crazy stuff bro so let's go ahead and
move on a little bit man let playstation
has announced they bought another studio
uh it's the it's jade studio what's that
studio actually called haven hey haven't
you so playstation announced that jade
raymond studio haven they acquired that
uh keep in mind uh
hustle have they made one game
no they have it but but but
there's no butt too fawn said they made
one game wait a minute no they have not
wait a minute hold on god damn it both
of y'all hold on wait a minute wait a
minute
now i believe it was herman host in the
interview that i read said he was
extremely impressed with what he saw
and
look i think he jumped
right that's cool i think he jumped on
the gun a little bit but you got to
understand team green put the pressure
on that boy over there man you got to
understand what just happened yo
microsoft like pretty much just bought
activision and before um before we get
back to what we were talking about the
shareholders
vote in favor if this deal doesn't go
through over their activision so they
want the deal for microsoft to happen i
i need to throw that little nugget out
there no you're right you're 100 right a
boy boy out there herman he's fighting
for his life right now man he got the
something got to change baby he's
fighting he
let him look i applaud this effort and i
hope whatever they you know
whatever type of financial backing that
playstation will give uh miss j in her
actual studio i hope it works out well
and they favor i hope they have like the
next last of us when they had less was
part one that part two so much but i
hope they got like the next big thing
when they have man and i love hustle
sometimes bro he says some great things
i like that bro you know
not not the last of us too so much
yeah
all right so
here here's where i stand all right
let's let's talk a little bit about the
studio itself uh you know
you know the the individual over the
studio she does have some clout so we
can't say she doesn't uh you know
there's a good chance she's gonna make
something i think the last time i
checked it was a multiplayer game isn't
it
i think so yes so do you guys take a
look first off let's talk let's talk
about the playstation
is doing serious investing to a
multiplayer infrastructure uh they they
they bought bungie and now it looks like
they're buying uh they bought haven so
they're buying these studios that uh
well maybe not haven but haven is kind
of
it was built to make multiplayer games
and what's what's interesting
is what is jade raymond's game because
i'm kind of curious last game was i
think assassin's creed wasn't that the
last thing she worked on
yeah assassin's creed uh
which one was it it was a long time ago
bro like black flag
yeah we're going way back oh god
okay let me take that back sony what you
do with why are you investing what's
this
she wasn't like she did had a studio for
a first party at stadia but
they didn't build anything like
they were gotten rid of before they even
started well that's not really her fault
but still no it's not her fault but what
i'm saying is like
her pedigree you know she does have some
good games under her belt but there's so
long ago that i i don't even remember
and the thing is is look she could be a
great developer and have a great team on
her hands but the first thing that i
thought of when i saw them that they
acquired haven the first thing that
popped in my mind was i thought it
already happened because i remember when
they were even announced as a studio and
they were being backed by sony uh to
build a multiplayer exclusive game like
a year and a half ago or so it might
have been two years ago i forgot when
that news dropped but when it did like
soon after i always thought man they
might as well acquire them so i already
thought they were acquired so when i saw
that news come out i was like this isn't
a big deal like i i thought they would
go that route anyway like okay
i get that
it's it's it's a
games as a service type game so it's a
live stream it is yeah but they but they
need that they they did didn't they hire
some ex destiny devs and stuff
like they got people over there it's
working on a lot of live service i think
i remember specifically they said
destiny but you know that's besides what
let's
let's talk about organic growth
uh or organically
oh oh [ __ ] now
i know they invested into the studio and
i know that they funded it to a point
but do you guys think that this is an
example
of organic growth 100
oh you think i think because this studio
basically started uh because of the
backing of sony i i think that's 100
organic um do i feel like this is
organic in a way
that a lot of people were pushing and
i'm talking like fanboy narratives you
know
when this whole discussion was being
talked about a year ago
where sony only you know acquires
studios that have uh that that have
they've had they built long
relationships with and they've had
success with with games no it's not like
that because there was no success here
yet there could be but yes it is
traditionally like
by by definition it's organic because
they were kind of funded by sony
originally so i will yeah i will give
you that
because because we're a big thing over
here we're talking like
you know
i don't believe
the narrative that people are pushing is
organic growth i think this is more
organic growth and obviously there's
joking like you know if if you look at
it from the standpoint or the fanboy
this is an organic growth but if you
look at it insomniac they worked with
them they said that's organic growth no
that's investing in the insomniac to
make gains for you and insomniac takes
the games that the money that they've
been that you've been feeding them and
they're growing their studio really had
nothing to do with playstation in my
opinion it's just as organic as say the
initiative with microsoft
because they're from the they're there
from the infancy stage like the close to
the emphasis and and somebody in the
chat flame with the two dollars says
it's not a live service game it's a sony
template game no it is a live service
game it's supposed to be a multiplayer
games as a service game i would like
that article from games
it's a games industry and i believe now
this is another point i wanted to bring
up
is i think that the the reason why
they're building upon this game this
haven studios is because this is going
to be one of the studios that i think is
going to funnel games into their
spartacus service i think their game
pass type service is going to have more
of these types of games going day and
date then say they're big aaa you know
single player narrative blockbusters
they're going to put more of these types
of games in their version of game pass
essentially
they're going to need to do that because
they got to keep up the game regardless
of what people like regardless of how
people feel about game pads the second
game pass
pc
syncs up with game pass on consoles and
the game players ultimately think it's a
real like thing in the way they're in
parody with each other i mean
playstation would be in big trouble see
i would never buy an xbox series s or x
i need to get one but there's certain
games that aren't on the cpc version of
it that i would love to go back and play
so places they're gonna have to find a
way to keep up and
hey look i hope it worked i hope it
worked out for man because i'm all for
you know i'm all for the growth and
development
i like i like nick's question in the
chat he says why does it matter if
something is organic an acquisition it
really doesn't that's a good question it
doesn't matter
we're just talking from
the standpoint of what we see the media
saying what we see in the twitter
streets like i've always felt like what
they do naughty dog that's organic
growth uh you know they took naughty dog
in their infancy stages and they and
they invested money into them helped
them bring in talent and nurtured them
up to making the games they're making
now you see it um with uh with the
people who made ghosts to sushima uh
sucker punch right
yeah sucker punch they went from uh
infamous they've nurtured them up to go
sushima that is what
emphasis that is what i feel like is
nurturing now i don't think insomniac's
nurturing i know people disagree with
you on that that is
playstation
funneling money into a studio and
they're they're taking that studio and
they're hiring from with that money like
for instance you know if they would have
bought in sonya
10 years ago five years ago and they've
built up to spiderman that's natural
organic growth
turn us up
turn you up up
yeah i'm listening to to what's now okay
we're kind of low
and
so
i just complete okay okay so it doesn't
matter at the end of the day
regardless if you buy a company
that already has that or you don't buy a
company you have to naturally grow that
the difference between those two type of
studios is money if if a studio has that
clout they've had that time they have
that organic growth they've grown for
years and they're making that type of
game you're probably gonna have to add
another zero to buy that type of game
but when you buy a game like compulsion
you nurture it from the start and then
you go from we happy feud whatever
they're doing after that whatever
they're doing after that that comes with
a shorter cost but maybe a greater
result at the end you get the same
result if you do it right regardless
what spectra of the side you're on
yeah one could argue its organic growth
with the acquisition of bethesda because
bethesda has had a long-standing
relationship since xbox's inception
uh they've with morrowind uh being the
first rpg on console like that um
bethesda's had a great relationship with
microsoft over the years uh that's
pretty organic as well but it doesn't
really matter at the end of the day it
comes down to develop
the developers talent um if you
acquire a talented team you're gonna you
know do well with that team if you let
them do what they do you know i i you
know
it's it's kind of silly to even you know
really push this whole uh it needs to be
organic or whatever
and that's what i've always stated like
when people say
sony does stuff that makes sense for
them no sony does stuff that they're
able to buy because people forget they
bid it for the people that may uh that
own uh
warframe they bid it for wb games
they bid it for these studios they just
get out bidded it's not that they don't
want to it's just they don't have money
to compete with the apples and the sewn
microsoft they don't have that type of
money to compete with tencent tencen's
the people that beat them in that in
that race with the warframe like they go
after studios that make sense to them
and the amount of money they have in the
bank that's why instead of them openly
going after bigger publishers they're
going to double down on their studios
because one takes an absurd amount of
money that you might not be able to come
up with now look people act like sony
can't buy companies like square enix
they can't but the question is is can
they convince investors to let them
spend that money that's the question
it's easier for microsoft to go to an
investor meeting say look i need 78
billion dollars to or however much it
was i can't remember to buy activision
when they look okay how much do we have
how much do we have in money
oh we got we got like look we got like a
trillion dollars in cash well obviously
i'm joking but when they look at that
they see all of that extra money is they
could take risks and keep in mind with
inflation going up that money is just
devaluing so they better invest that
before actually is worth less than it is
now this time next year
so
i agree at the end of the day
i i'm excited uh you know we're going to
see a different sony you know people
keep saying that you know we're already
seeing a different sony bro it's already
happening well i've been things that are
out of their comfort zone for years now
we're seeing the the the starting roots
that's going to lead to a tree in the
future yeah and you know
it's exciting because
it is and then you know let's talk a
little bit about gran turismo
all right okay do we have to though yeah
all right we got you it's everywhere man
it's everywhere
how do you slander how do you guys feel
about this situation that's going on
with grand transport seven we'll start
with uh we'll start with hustle first
cool um i'll make this quick um
polyphony did this right it's polyphony
digital yeah yeah science surprise
because i remember
a very long time ago 2006 and i
mentioned this on the podcast before i
remember 2006 um shout out to g4 um
morgan webb had actually broke down
everything with i forgot what gran
turismo it was but in order for you to
buy everything in that game and this is
when dlc was unheard of like that in
order for you to buy everything in that
game i think you needed to spend like
four grand about everything that to
about everything in that game or you had
to like play like hell this is the same
thing all over again man i'm cool i'm
cool on that man i'm sure the game is
fun i'm you know i shout out to jay gat
he know who he is
him and har hey they've been playing it
and having a great time and everything
shout out to them but
i'm not surprised man
i'm more
i don't know like i feel like
we have a grasp on
on this our community in general right
like we see a ton of people making
videos about it like how did you ever
think you were to get away with
something like that as far as having all
the micro transactions in it without
somebody saying without having somebody
saying something about it like how do
you how long do you think you're gonna
get away with all that well see they
need to know that for me they didn't
think they'd get away with it that's why
they implemented it after the reviews
came out
uh
they updated uh the metrics and how how
much stuff cost what you got for this
like they what they did with that game
every reviewer that reviewed that game
should went back and redid their review
every single one of them but it seems
like all they did was just go in there
and be like they updated the game a
couple days after i reviewed it but
instead of punishing them for it and
re-reviewing it to a point they're like
we're just going to give you an uh like
some kind of update at the bottom of the
review it's like but it's not the same
game anymore it doesn't change the score
yeah yeah
and that that's blows my mind because
all you're doing there is showing oh
sony's like oh that works
like
it's like what else can we do that was
do you
do you remember the backlash that uh it
was uh what was it forza motorsport
seven got
when that was transformed
and they were talking about the micro
transactions and they got dinged for it
and they weren't even in the game so
reviewers were dinging them for micro
transactions in their reviews
you know there wasn't any micro
transactions in it i got a question and
shout out to da da da yo his name crazy
in the chat um so this game apparently
is it's a single player game right is
this game against a single player
so why does it need to be always online
apparently
microtransactions
and you know what's funny they they go
out and they say stuff like we do it
because of the cheaters we don't want to
give a bad example in the place we play
that that's all smoke screens all they
do it because they don't want people
hacking into the game and getting all of
these cars where they don't get the
money from the microtransfer it's it's
and they they've said as much and this
is why i argue with people when i talk
about the microtransactions being so
egregious and people arguing with me
saying you don't have to buy them though
fonz and it's like but look you're
paying 70 for a product which is forcing
you to go online and they said yeah
that's what we have a problem with is it
being always online well then you have a
problem with the micro transactions
because they go hand in hand the reason
why you're online with this game is
because they're keeping track of your
credits that you earn
towards getting those cars and of course
you have to play a lot of races to earn
any of these cars because they they cost
a lot of money so they are essentially
pushing you towards those micro
transactions just because you didn't buy
them doesn't mean that you know joe
schmo is not buying him because he's not
about to you know raise 700 laps on a
certain course just to get one car and
what's crazy is it's insane i saw in a
um
someone put like a chart on twitter
that said a certain car in there i think
it was like 10 million or 18 million or
something like that
that castle it took 20 hours of game
play to get that car
yeah
can you what's the call what's the call
it was like a mclaren or something like
that i don't know but
when you're talking big money like
claire yeah but this is a game this is
it i never want to know like
so sony said speaking of that sony said
themselves they wanted real world
pricing within the game and i'm thinking
to myself when i'm playing a video game
i don't want to deal with real world you
know what i want to play these cars you
know
you know what's funny they said they
want real world pricing
okay then you should have
circuits and stuff that give you real
world prizes
like
there you go but they don't do that like
they're nickel and diming
like they might do that but it's quicker
to do smaller races to get to get you
know more money quicker quicker but it's
just like to me i don't understand why
people just let this slide no one said
nothing no one like i i when this
happened and they hit that on switch
i saw very few people speak out against
this
very few people this isn't a microsoft
thing this isn't a sony thing this isn't
a a nintendo s thing this is if you let
them do this
other companies are going to do this you
literally just told them you can do
whatever the hell you want in a game
just set it for a patch after the
reviews because no one's going to call
you out on it
and you know maybe that's because you
know we got to be real here they're
sony's been very notorious
for blacklisting people when they say
anything they don't like about their
games
and i have to i have to correct albert g
yes halo infinite is always online but
you can play the campaign offline you
can
yeah because the the multiplayer is the
uh the
faction that's online it's just like i
just got really i didn't get upset but i
just got frustrated it's just like how
did no one call them out on this like no
one it's the same thing that doesn't
make did you but but that's the thing
and you brought it up earlier when they
made these reviews all the reviewers
they didn't have the credit system all
in place just yet so they didn't have
the transactions they didn't know how
much all this stuff was going to cost
and then that conveniently comes out
after the reviews are posted
that's what i don't like and the crazy
part fawns is it's like
these same reviewers they didn't say
nothing like they they did a little
update and they did that because they
they did that for their own energy they
didn't do that because it was the right
thing they do they put that in the
review because they wanted people to
know because they didn't want someone to
go there look at a review
see the review play the game and say why
didn't you tell me about any of this so
obviously they're going to update the
reviews so people don't give them that
kind of stigma
and that that's that's that's the part
that blows my mind it's like
like fawn said a few years back we did
the
uh forza motorsport seven there wasn't
even micro transactions in the game and
they got digging for it
but this game
this this is even worse than
microtransactions in the review this is
sneaking microtransactions in the back
door after yeah
and that's ten times worse but no albert
albert g come on stop it bro he says gt7
rewards dedicated playing so that's what
we're calling it now if you want to get
a mclaren you have to be dedicated and
spend 20 hours just for that one car
no what i call that is a you know a
raping of sorts because
listen to this like you're looking at
this situation where you've got a 70
game with the mo some of the most
egregious you know
microtransactions out there and you are
defending that
let's let's look at that you know this
whole scenario
next gen gaming oh it should cost 70
i would gladly pay 70 dollars for
quality why because games should be more
prices
more higher in price because things are
getting more expensive yes but you know
there was mitigating factors for this
and that was micro transactions that's
why for years we haven't had price
increases for games because of these
egregious practices and we've been
dealing with this forever but now
they're getting their cake and eating it
too they're getting the extra ten
dollars from you plus those egregious
micro transactions you're just taking it
in the rear and loving it and i don't
see why i don't see why they literally
charge these individuals 70
and then put it'd be different if they
had things in here to to accommodate for
this like i don't know if this is in
here in the chat correct me but i did
i'm not seeing it at all they had some
kind of you know test driving thing
where you could test drive a vehicle or
something to that nature i've not seen
anyone refer to that they might have
that um i've been told you can't sell
cars is that true i've been told you
cannot sell cars in gran turismo no you
can't so you can't sell the car if you
look at it from
a multiplayer aspect where they made it
always online it's debatable why they
did it but i'm pretty sure we all know
why they did it they did it so people
don't play this game they don't take
their hacked ps5 or ps4 or whatever the
case may be
hack and get you all of these cars
play it offline and never log in and
they can have all these vehicles because
they don't want you doing that what they
want you to do is give them this money
that's what they want you to do i've
always had no issue with
putting microtransactions in the game
for a shortcut as long as the base game
wasn't fluffed
for instance
i loved the assassin's creed games the
newer ones now i do agree that
i i i love my older assassin's creeds
more but these are okay they're good
games they have
this xp system that was in odyssey it
was a change like that and
so they pretty much let's say they take
a hundred percent the game was supposed
to be these hundred percent great scale
when the game came out they cut it to 50
and they sold you the extra 50
so it's just like when you do stuff like
that to enforce them spending money
where it's not an option they're
encouraging you and not only are they
encouraging you they're punishing you
that you're not doing it
that's why i have the difference of
opinion and i think it's wrong and
they're punishing you by keeping you
always online for these
microtransactions mind you and you guys
don't even see it all you guys think is
oh i hate when the servers are down and
i can't play the game why can't i play
offline it's a single player game it's
because of those micro transactions
start thinking start talking with your
wallet if a game is 70 dollars
and it's a single player game there
should be zero microtransactions in it
and if they are there don't buy them
just don't you know what was a good
what a good like
i don't even like the cosmetic stuff
look here's how i like microtransactions
uh if they're done i would prefer them
gone i like microtransactions where
like destiny okay destiny's micro
transactions is crazy but what they do
do in this is they're like look
the hot [ __ ] this season you're not
getting you're just not like
you're not getting these for the most
part now you can they will show up in
the every verse every now and then but
it's just like but if you stay with this
till next season we're gonna put all
this hot [ __ ] this season and every
verse regularly next season so you don't
have to spend a penny if you want this
stuff it's just if you want it now
you're gonna have to open up your pocket
i like that type of system now i would
prefer they just gave it to me
nightfalls and stuff but clearly we in
in a realm of that doesn't exist
but when you
destiny gives you rewards for doing it
they're like look we're going to give
this gold this this bright dust that you
can get throughout the year and when
stuff pops out in the eververse you just
go get it with that currency that's a
good way of doing stuff now
i don't like the way that assassin's
creed did their stuff and g and gran
turismo 7's doing this stuff because to
me
that is asking the player to go above
and beyond to get stuff that they should
naturally get through progression of the
game
yeah and you should make that
progression harder and and and patch it
to to get even harder to get those
credits in those cars and make them more
expensive that is what's really
egregious here and the thing is at the
end of the day again i have to bring up
the whole you know the fact that we were
you know not being charged 70 for so
many years or extra for these games we
were at that 60 dollar price point for
so long because of these mitigating
factors micro transactions dlcs uh
season passes collectors editions you
know what if you want to charge 70
dollars for a game get rid of all those
mitigating factors stop and i'll gladly
pay 70 dollars for the games no problem
but until you do so i am not paying 70
dollars for your games because you
continue to do this sort of thing and
nickel and dimas and we're not fools as
consumers we can see this stuff at least
i'm no fool and i know you aren't addict
and you aren't hustle you see this stuff
going on well slow down slow down
i get stupid sometimes but here's what i
will say now i'm playing here's what i
will say right
about as far as the micro transactions
even the price increase i know you said
you gladly paid for that here's the
thing man i i wouldn't and i'll tell you
why because there are more people
playing the game playing games than
there ever has been so that's true and
that is one of the mitigating factors as
well it is true but i'm just saying if
they got rid of every freaking
microtransactions and dlcs that is you
know uh that they are using to their
advantage nowadays they're actually
keeping content from some games just to
bring it out later for more money and
stuff if they got rid of all that stuff
yeah then that's when i say okay
do the 70 price point have like the
games whole at the start none of this bs
going on then yeah
i'm good with it but other than that no
70 the game shouldn't be 70 dollars it
just shouldn't
i mean well you know that's that's i
mean i feel like no no game should be 70
dollars like we i see kirby um
curbing in the forgotten last the first
3d kirby ever which apparently is
getting really good reviews i think it
comes out in two days i do believe um
that game is 69 or 59 dollars so i mean
that just is what it is like i feel like
if you make good product people to go
buy a good product animal crossing will
like literally can can literally tell
you everything that you need to know a
lot of people call that a pandemic game
and that was again came out at the right
time
it don't matter yo 20 million over 20
million people wouldn't bought that like
that's i think that's right sitting like
30 million like that's that's wild to me
and it's 50
so i say that all the time bro a good
product will sell yep that's where
we don't get to worry about the next
don't worry about the next grand theft
auto coming now and then
regardless of what it is like people
gonna scoop it off the shelf man it's
like i've always said
it doesn't matter
what your previous history is like i get
it cyberpunk
they did you know cd projekt red did
some crazy stuff with cyberpunk oh they
dropped it but if they come out with
that witcher and it's like you play yeah
and it's game of the year stuff
yeah people are gonna forget it's funny
people are very fickle that way uh
especially gamers when it comes to
certain development teams and you know
if they drop the ball on a certain game
but then they come out and mention the
witcher and they're like oh my god the
witcher is coming in everybody's excited
again the cd project red is great again
you know e as much as i loved cyberpunk
2077 because i did love my play through
with that game uh
but i i can't deny that they didn't drop
the ball i mean they did a lot of wrong
there especially for the old consoles
telling people that it ran great and
then it didn't
run very well at all on those consoles
it was just a mess and you know i i
totally they deserve everything they got
for that all the heat
yeah and
look at at the end of the day you know
we got this two dollar super chat from
god's hitman
talk about the new meeting between xbox
and activision do you have any idea what
he's i know that they're on like the
next process and they're meeting to
buying it look man i'll be real with you
god's hit man i'm not a lawyer i don't
know anything about that process hey
first off your name is crazy i like it
though i like it though um i don't know
if that was what i was referring to
earlier when we were talking about um
how the certain shareholders want to
come in just in case this deal doesn't
go through and they still want microsoft
to acquire um activision itself
so i don't know if or like the entire
activision i don't know if that is where
it came from um god said man if you were
still here let me know because i didn't
i didn't hear it i didn't see nothing
about that yo and shout out real quick i
don't know if he follows y'all but he
damn don't follow me and he'd be hitting
me off with news articles all the time
shout out to the finest on twitter oh
yeah that boy different man he just go
he's always hitting with news articles
all the time bro he hits up everybody i
think good guy i appreciate him yup yeah
i definitely appreciate them but that i
don't know if you're referring to that
so so let me know so let me know what's
up forte we see you down there
yeah what's up forte we got two options
from don otaku uh assassins creed new
her no
what is assassin's creed new york
horizons yeah hitting 40 million as an
exclusive
um is that is that their new game is new
horizon
no it's don don of ragnarok dawn of new
york i don't know dlc yeah
i don't know
i don't know what that's about but you
know i get that look at the end of the
day
it's not necessarily i care about what
you know that
what the people who make gran turismos
do into their to their
player base because i don't i don't care
about that game like and to be honest
with you if you bought that
you know yeah but
i here's where i i kind of disagree is i
don't like practices like this because
it sets precedence oh yeah and it starts
trends sometimes and if people are okay
with what gt7 is doing now they're going
to be okay with the next installment and
or the next game they decide to make and
it's just like where does it end um i i
don't want to see this trend continue
especially at a 70 price point i don't
care like that's just and i agree with
you and it's like that's why i brought
up earlier about like the
the
the chat the the reviewers not saying
nothing because if the reviewers would
have revolted and they would have
re-reviewed the games and they would
have gate oh and it's metacritic
what
yeah no ac stands for animal crossing
i'm sorry
i don't talk my fault
he said the same creed i'll go right
along my fault my
uh yeah new horizons
oh yeah that's right animal crossings
new horizons
i think you could safe to assume that
none of us played that game but look i
didn't yeah
at the end of the day if the reviewers
would have stood their ground and they
would have re-reviewed the game imagine
if it went from an 87 to like a 7 73 or
74. then oh yeah the next time this will
happen sony's like yo last time we just
we destroyed our metacritic score let's
not do that again allegedly allegedly we
can we can't
we can't you said you mentioned
something earlier i wanted to stop you
adam you can't say for sure that tony is
just doing that tony's doing that i i i
will say so
here's the thing if sony wasn't doing
that those those micro transactions
would came out with their views the fact
that they put them in there after the
reviews were posted meant they
deliberately put that system in there
after the reviews posted because they
wanted to not let them affect the scores
of the game
and that's wrong and no one called them
out on and it is what it is and
hopefully you know people that ship will
get corrected i wanted to get corrected
because i feel like you know we we
like font said we're paying 70 dollars
for games well
i
and you could i mean you could even be
enjoying the game i get it but if you
out there if you're out there like
defending these practices
seriously you need to stop this it's not
a good look for you or and for the
consumer base the gamers none of us like
this is bad and and you got to call it
out when it is bad and this is truly bad
it doesn't matter what platform this
would have been on had it been on xbox
nintendo it don't matter i would have
said something bad about this that's
what i was like
this isn't on playstation thing this
isn't an xbox thing if anyone would have
done this i feel like the response
should be the same thing like
that's why i feel about like broken
games
same thing you know we give people too
many slack like yeah when broken games
come out xbox needs to pull that sucker
off the store playstation needs to pull
that sucker off the store now obviously
i don't mean like
games that have a little bit of glitches
in them and you know i mean games it's
like cyberpunk battlefield 5 halo master
chief collection and you know eldon ring
it was a little bit there at the
beginning on par with that but it never
quite went that high
it was never that bad wait a minute
on pc i heard that it was it was kind of
weird like it had issues it was uh it
was a lot of stuttering a whole lot of
stuttering on pc um i think they kind of
corrected that with the latest patch i
think it's patch 106 or something like
that i think they fixed it with that
because when i
oh we got to kill let's cause when i
played that just now it wasn't um
oh when i played it because when i
played it sunday it was it was cool
everything's seen yeah
everything seemed to run normal on elden
ring but um
yeah um
you know
everybody we all kind of got to stand up
with you know when it comes to like the
micro transactions the same way we all
stood up for um when xbox was trying to
make xbox gold um trying to double the
price we all kind of stood up on that
one we
so we all got to do that so that's our
responsibility most of us did there were
a couple of xbox dudes that were like
hey guys you know price increase hasn't
happened so you know i'm just like
better shut up i think when it comes to
me is
i don't want the price increase but
i know it's inevitable and there's
nothing i can do to stop it i'm there
too it's inevitable
and especially the part that sucks the
most is being a content creator some of
these games like i'm expected to buy to
cover to review to stream so i'm in a
[ __ ] situation because
i have to support the nonsense to get
content out because of the nonsense to
get content on the nonsense but you know
that's all i'm saying man like you could
go out there you could play grand
transplant ain't nobody gonna say
nothing uh i see the people that love
that type of gameplay they're loving it
so kudos to you man you got a solid
product that is being ran by criminals
uh but you know let's
let's man he said criminals that that's
that look man that's hey it is criminal
behavior i'll tell you that it's very
egregious yeah
it's it's crazy how they did it but it
is what it is let's get to the main
event of the evening let's do it all
right so we got two titles we're going
to talk about fable
made by playground games
and hellblade
made by ninja theory uh we had one
individual that has worked for both of
these developers uh these developers
uh he
left playground games and went back to
uh uh ninja engineering it did seem like
he went back i think that's how i read
it so pretty much he said that you know
hellblade is
it's kind of like a little bit of a slow
pace like he didn't say it was like
anything bad over there he just said
it's not moving as fast as they would
hope because it is something drastically
different and they in where they don't
have a studio built around rpgs because
when you have like from software go from
uh secure shadow dies twice to eldon
ring
regardless if there's two kind of
different type of games they're the same
type of gameplay but you have a company
such as playground games just went from
you know gran
forza horizon 5 forza horizon 4
and now they're going to something like
fable they have a second studio you
might hire people to go in there but the
studio when it was built was not
fostered around that particular type of
genre so you're gonna have a little bit
of hiccups there because
it's it's a live and learn kind of thing
now they did hire people from lionhead
uh ex-lionhead
developers i hope that community manager
didn't get hired because i heard uh he
was one of the reasons that fable was uh
always going downhill because he was
always he was always
crazy what the promise is man but you
know we weren't going to him too much
but but he went back to ninja theory and
uh you know he brought that up and i'm
not saying he's not wrong because he is
uh he he's right uh i i would assume
that they do have a good amount of
people over there that's worked on type
of rpgs but i understand that you know
when the bulk of the work's probably
being worked on people that's made a
different type of genre it's going to be
a little bit of of of a transition and i
think that's what he was really
referring to it's like he wasn't really
trying to say the studio is doing bad he
was saying like look
it's a little bit slower in progression
because they're doing something new so
clearly it's going to have
like a form of
uh so
it kind of kind of sounds like this guy
pulled a drew murray you know he went
for one company and then went back he
went from a microsoft company to another
microsoft company
no but this guy
i'm just saying that you know he kind of
went went away for a little while and
then went back to his original studio
and he's like i feel more comfortable
here the way that
it was he described it is he left
around the time that uh
that they were about towards the end of
uh hellblade
and he wanted he likes the beginning
process he likes being the creative
process at the beginning yeah that makes
a lot of sense some i could see
developers being more creative in that
aspect and he makes a lot of sense when
he talks about playground games starting
a whole different type of genre i mean
this is totally new for playground right
they're going from a racing franchise to
a you know
a third person action adventure
essentially
you know it's a very different genre a
very different game so
yeah i don't know how that works but i
would assume that it would be slower
like he said in in uh make building upon
this game but
um yeah i i don't know i don't you know
i can't disagree with the guy
it's probably right you know he's
probably 100 correct there all right
albert g i'm sure you're trolling but
we're going to entertain your trolliness
kojima made a new studio and came out
with a game with no problems so it's
possible
um i'm pretty sure
what game was it that's strange
i'm pretty sure
i'm i'm 100 sure that when sony signed
that man's check for him to make death
stranding they didn't expect him to make
something like that strandy and there's
a reason why they didn't sign up for a
death trendy two because i'm sure sony
themselves playing that game had no idea
what this man was thinking when he made
that look
people love what that man does and i get
it i get it he does
quality work and people love his stuff i
personally feel like he belongs in a
straight jacket but that's just oh man
i'm with you i personally feel he's a
bit overrated but that's just me no like
some of the like go back and look at
some of those older trailers like this i
will say i feel like
i feel like kojima's
visions belong in the movie scene not in
the gaming scene i i think you would be
a better director than a game developer
there's a lot of people that love little
caesar's pizza and there's millions of
franchises out there and you know it's
it's horrible pizza uh
it's a million people there's millions
of people who like trash ponds i said
that's what we're going to roll with
it happened all right that's all i'm
saying you know well that's right oh my
god awful it's it's god awful all right
so
back to the fable thing like you know
first of all i want to ask you guys
first do you have any kind of
concern after hearing this about the
fable franchise well going forward not
the past ones and second
uh what do you think fable is coming out
because obviously people thought like
2024
um i i still think 2024
beginning of 2024 is a pretty good
reasonable thing but we're going to
start with uh with hustle because uh i
don't like the way he just signed so go
go go hustle i'm reading the chat that's
why um no if you're asking me when this
game is coming out
because they got announced um that they
were doing this project back in 2018
with uh when microsoft had the epic e3
memphis you know announced in fact he
announced the acquisition of ninja 32.
when
when we first heard that i would have
figured the joint would have dropped
next year sometime right but this is you
know this is their first time making a
game like this because they typically do
racing games
according to what you guys are telling
me now because i had no knowledge of
this if i had to guess i would say 2025
2026 which kind of goes along with the
theory that i've had the whole time
hey microsoft friend to do
numbers numbers with perfect dark and
fable and all these about and all these
other games this is gonna be like hit
after hit after hit and hey look i don't
know playstation no nintendo gonna be
able to withstand i think i think it'll
lead to microsoft doing great things if
those games all live up to the the hype
at least the hype that i'm putting out
there man cause i think it's going to be
dope but i think 2026
2022
now 2025. i feel comfortable saying that
i'll give about another three years i'll
get enough 20 25. i'm getting that three
years man y'all
yeah
i kind of agree with him i kind of agree
with hustle i think it's going to happen
yeah i think we
we possibly won't even see
anything from uh fable until
2024
um
yeah it look
if this is what he's saying a developer
there because you you have to like if
i'm going to believe anybody i'm going
to believe the developers from the teams
and stuff and if this guy is saying yeah
it's a slow process over there it's
really moving slow because uh you know
this is their first delve into this
genre and everything they're not used to
this
man
and they're saying he's saying that now
that's telling me it's not coming out
for some years bro like man you guys are
bursting my bubble but
isaac it's not to say it's going to be
bad or anything i don't know but this i
was expecting some gameplay by like next
year at e3
yeah i don't i don't see that happening
not game play if we don't see game play
you might see another teaser trailer no
i don't want to see no damn teaser
trailer i want to see games i see a
fable splash screen with a little fairy
flying through the place you know hold
on hold on y'all hold up hold up hold up
hey uh fooly time in that chat hey don't
no perfect dog slander i will block you
in this joint no perfect dog slander we
slow down you slow down in that chat um
i'm sorry hustle i got a lot of perfect
dark slander but yeah hey sir sir mm-hmm
sorry please don't be the first one
i just think there's problems with the
initiative i'll just tell you that much
i think there's problems there yeah um
if you if you saw the podcast last week
me and addict was talking about it i'm a
little concerned my damn self to be
honest with you and like that that
turnover that turn over like we i guess
we'll see turnovers like that in the
industry but won't really hear too much
about it we don't see see that that
often but when that list came out it's
like that's a big four
that's a lot of people and a lot of them
are senior level creativity you know
that is a lot of freaking people
but here in this situation with fable
though at least at playground games
you're not seeing a mass exodus of
developers
so you just hear this one guy saying
yeah it's a little slow process
that's expected but
you know you're not seeing a bunch of
them saying hey uh creativity's being
stifled um the the hierarchy there is
top down it's really heavy and it's it's
a one-man show over there and it's daryl
gallagher he's the only guy you're not
hearing this kind of stuff coming out of
playground which is a good thing
so this is a very good thing at least
you're not getting that uh that's why i
worry about the initiative in perfect
dark
yeah
i don't care about perfect dark to be
honest with you look i want a big fan of
the game i want the game to do well
because i feel like the initiative has
something to prove
but if that game came out and it flopped
it wouldn't bother me it really would it
bothered the hell out of me let me see
it would bother me only that this is a
studio that started with microsoft and
was supposed to be touted originally as
a quadruple a studio yeah it would
bother me a lot because you want to see
a brand new studio like this do really
well and i don't care if it was with
playstation and haven studios i want to
see them do do really well as as well
but
you know for me it's it's about that
it's about you know good putting a good
product out there i'm not a massive
perfect dark fan at all in fact i think
it's a a budget golden eye rip-off you
know oh man i think i think rare i think
rare
rare tried to capitalize on that kind of
genre because you know what they did
with gold and i and they failed in my
opinion because i didn't like perfect
dark i thought it was just not very good
but
that said that the party has just
started ladies and gentlemen go ahead
the reboot the the whole reboot
the only place i was really excited is i
was thinking okay you know i'm not a fan
of perfect dark but hopefully they make
this a third-person action adventure i
love and then you saw that it was first
person and i'm like really i i love
person again that hustle just kanye
wasted your ass fonts i will let you
finish i'm gonna let you i'm glamorous
but you know you know at the end of the
day it doesn't really matter because
this is just my opinion yeah um i i just
think that i just want a great product
from them i do want to see a good
perfect dark game from them
um and i still hope that i just have my
doubts because of the situation at hand
because of what daryl gallagher did
bringing in uh his team essentially a
bunch of yes men that's the way i view
it um he a lot of these creative
directors and stuff that have left the
studio already were already citing the
fact that creativity was being stifled
daryl wasn't letting them really have
much say he was very heavy-handed in the
project he's redirecting the project
several times already he's like nope
changing the direction of the game
that is not a good that's not a good
sign and then when he brings a bunch of
his guys over that he's used to working
with what does that scream it screams i
brought a bunch of yes men over to
listen to me
they're just going to do what i say
that's the my that's my assumption it's
not i could be happy
i do 100 agree with that but it could be
one of those scenarios where you get all
these people
that are used to being head of their
divisions that used to be in head of
entire departments and they were
bickering with each other too much i
don't think that's the case i think it's
a little bit of everything i think uh
you know daryl gallagher might be a
little bit too it's my way or the
highway but sometimes
when the captain steers the ship right
it works out it just depends if we can
rely on him to steer the ship in the
right way we got to fight all this
superstar from don hotaku perfect dart
was oh god look
he's very wrong perfect art was better
than golden eye in every way possible
fun bad taste
is back with the bad tanks everything is
right in the world
all of us old heads would disagree with
you golden knight is a classic that
donald tucker you are welcome on this
podcast anytime my friend i swear listen
listen fox you you you bugger you you're
wild listen listen
what go what what perfect dog
did after golden eye was made let's make
it like golden eye in space with a chick
in the alien that you could play as to
like listen man with the story you know
what uh worse you know just
to me it just
it was such a cheap like knockoff like
it just felt like okay
they put a a a chick in space and here
you go here's his golden eye all over
but this time a woman in space and and
and it's like it wasn't the same to me
goldeneye holds
i think i have just a bias for goldeneye
because it was one of my favorite games
n64 yeah all day man and uh it was it
was just a fantastic game in my opinion
and and i just always felt that uh
perfect dark wasn't that great and then
the second uh perfect dark game that
came out on the 360 i believe or was it
the
yeah i believe it was a 360. it wasn't
very good at all that was even worse i
felt like so
xbox did a really bad job at coming out
the gate with those franchises in good
ways like if you look at it
banjo-kazooie nuts and bolts a lot of
people feel like that's the worst by far
that was the first game out the gate
then you got the new perfect dart that
was the first one out the gate like i
feel like
if you let people work on these titles
i've been a very big advocate on badger
kazoo i know i'm like i know i'm hated
for that and that's fine i will be that
villain that everyone needs i will be
the one that's standing at the top of
the gate
and i've kidnapped half of the board to
make my banjo kazooie like look at at
the end of the day
regardless how bad your kazooie it does
or does not turn out you know what else
we're going to talk about today we're
talking about hellblade
we've got a little bit of bad news in
terms of fable and i wouldn't even say
it's bad news it's just i don't think
it's bad yeah it's interpretative news
just depending on how you feel that it
went but i feel like we got some good
news from hellblade because the same
individual said that he feels like the
combat in hellblade has been overhauled
dramatically
thank goodness
holy crap was that combat in the first
game so bad in my opinion
hellblade i i couldn't even finish it
because the to me it's it's very dull
it's it i'm not a big puzzle in-game
puzzle fan anyway and the puzzles in
that game matching up those things uh
the signs and stuff it's just dumb to me
and then and then the combat was very
lackluster i've always like i'm not the
biggest fan of hellblade because like it
messes with my mental thing with like
the whispering and stuff but
like i've always felt like what stands
out with
that game in particular
is you know the the talking in the the
ears like i feel like it should be one
of those things where
that's the direction that the puzzles go
through where you hear whispering and
stuff like that like that's what they
need to build on they
i think the combat if you take good
combat and you put that in hellblade
i feel like that game would have
drastically improved been better oh yeah
yeah i would have finished it you know
i can't get through that game i can't
man it that combat is not good and that
was the very first thing i said when
when i heard hellblade 2 was being in
production i said
hopefully they change that combat and it
looks like that's what they're doing big
time i mean they they had everybody
including molina um but including the uh
some of the developers even get in there
and in mocap suits and train actual
mixed martial arts and stuff so they are
actually training to do all this stuff
so they got a better understanding on
how to create this stuff how to
implement it within the the combat of
the game
that is exciting news so
for some reason i feel like
i might not be the biggest fan of
hellblade
but i feel like hellblade 2 about to
come out and it's about to come out like
in hits
yeah i think so too i think this is a
situation where the sophomore outing
will be the better of the two for sure
i feel like
all right let's take the original
studios they bought like with three four
three and then i feel like three four
three is gonna eventually correct the
[ __ ] for halo hopefully it's not too
late uh you know just depends on what
they do they can always get the people
back it's just they're gonna need
something drastic to get them back but
but let's uh you know with three four
three the only
man i'm still on my hate train a bit
with three four three even though i
liked halo infinite campaign i thought
it was very good uh it was a solid
outing you know but i think a lot of
that had to do with um bringing back uh
what's his name uh joseph staton
um and i think as long as he stays at
the helm it could be a good thing it it
it should be a good thing
but if he were to step back or be pulled
off and and 343 goes its own way i think
they'll slide again because right now i
mean if you look at it halo infinite was
finished uh by the time it was finished
the development team consisted of 30 to
50 percent of just uh people they had
from outside sources they weren't even
part of 343
they were just brought in to help 30 to
50 percent of the development team
was like that
i i don't know what's going on now with
them but yeah you're right and then
uh but i think i think with ninja theory
ninja theory has grown exponentially
under xbox and ninja theory has always
had some great games under their belt
they've got a great pedigree just
because i didn't like hellblade doesn't
mean i didn't like their older games
hell i just put out a tweet last night
talking about heavenly sword i loved
heavenly sword it wasn't the best game
out there mechanically or anything but
damn it was good it was a lot of good
fun
we got a five dollar super chat from
tonitaku ninja theory are combat gods
but it was clear they skipped over it
because of the budget and small team i
have faith that uh hellblade 2 will
correct that now look let's talk about
the studios all right like i said i
think bungie will eventually not bungee
i think three four three well they'll
eventually correct the ship now
regardless if there's a game there to
save once they save it uh you know it
it's debatable now i've always felt like
it doesn't matter
all this talks nice but if they do what
they supposed to they'll get those
players back it just
the longer it takes the less chance they
have of the biggest result all right
they then we talk about uh you know uh
people make gears uh the cultural
coalition the coalition sir yes sir
i feel like i'm not in trouble at all
bro i feel like it's just fine i feel
like they they put the entire xbox one
generation on their back
like that whole xbox one uh i believe
compulsion's gonna come out with a solid
game i don't know if it's gonna be like
amazing or anything but i think people
are gonna enjoy it i think that obsidian
is going to hit out the park every time
i i've never
that might be the best studio like
obsidian is their insomniac in my
opinion yeah
oh okay that's hold on hold on hold on
fast now that's how i praise now see
yeah that's because
okay so here's here's the thing just
like insomniac they put out a lot of
good product quality product all the
time so obsidian has put out a lot of
games
underneath most likely is coming out
next year and they uh they just had a
game like two years ago
yep and and they're always winners man
obsidian in my opinion
they they have done no wrong in gaming
like i like all their games that i've
played if you look at it okay so they
made couture too
they made the best fallout ever they
made fallout new vegas they made south
park stick of truth which is a
phenomenal game
they
they they and then their pillars of
eternity is
considered to be the best in that genre
yeah and then you know you have the
outer worlds which a lot of people feel
is fallout in space better
and then you're going to have something
like you know avow the vow is supposed
to be their answers the elden rings
elder scroll type of games uh regardless
if they pulled that off bro
that's debate when i feel like there's a
good chance we see their stuff this year
at e3
whatever that yep that conference is
going to be i feel like
they you know what's crazy they actually
have a really solid year if you think
about it unless they butcher this and
don't show none of this stuff we're
definitely going to see starfield we're
going to most likely see
a vowed
and
what else we might see compulsions game
because i would say that's probably
coming close to getting done it's a good
time man like regardless what's going on
with fable we might see fable a little
longer it's okay to wait for fable as
long as they're giving us stuff
until then i think that's been the
biggest issue of xbox is they want us to
wait but they don't want to give us
anything to wait with
uh you know we might see a new fallout
like lord metro put in there because
clearly uh you know jeff grubb shout out
to him he said that
you know there was talks maybe doing a
sequel to fallout new vegas now
well would you like them to be more like
sony in the respect where they show
games
uh
years out like wolverine you know i
would be okay with that
as long as i'm okay with it i would be
okay with that as long as they get their
look you get one
cgi scene with me one cgi trailer that's
what you rebuild the game with that's
the fableds that's the uh the outer
worlds two but if you show that sucker
again i want to gain play with it yes
exactly that's how i feel too however
you know then you're going to be called
uh you know a hypocrite because of
bethesda and the way they work their
thing uh they will show you hardly
anything and then they'll talk about the
game forever and then they won't show
gameplay till six to eight months out
before the game releases
and that's just how they've always done
things going back to even you know
skyrim for instance i think they finally
showed game play in at the end of
february before it came out that
november and that's when they showed any
game play darren hurston we said we got
contraband next year so you know we look
xbox is in a good place now i know that
you know we got to see
the games they got to execute them right
but
as of right now even with what they're
doing they've done a good job of
entertaining us they've done a good job
of showing us quality titles that came
out like psychonauts like clearly they
didn't buy trashy studios they bought
good studios that could make good
products it just
was a game of the year contender
it just depends
on can they elevate these studios can
can they
nurture these studios with money and
talent buying with the money where it's
going to make these studios produce
better content so we got a ten dollar
superchat from donnataku people put
insomniac on a too high of a pedestal a
sonia just started putting out good
games that weren't grand uh ratchet
games obscenia has never made a bad game
and consistently put out games i will
agree with you i actually feel like
obsidian is a better game than a song
yet that's just me because slow down
that's just like look no but
hold up hold on hold on let let me he's
got he could have that opinion okay
as far as doing what they do
insomniac is well known for making
platforming games the ratchet and
playing and i would say spider-man's a
platinum horror two to an extent
it's it's kind of like a freeloading
platformer where you know you you you're
swinging through the city instead of
like going on one bible you got to get
what i'm saying everything blurs the
line between platforming and action
adventure even with ratchet and clank it
blurs those lines and so
see
they do what they do well
but if you look at something like
obsidian
they have done rpgs in every category
and hit it out the park every time it's
not something that's a little bit like
regardless how you feel about insomniac
they make good gains but they do have
occasional okay that was a good game
such as like um um
what's that game they made for xbox
um you saw mother oh i just played that
game oh yeah shots at overdrive sunset
overdrive
game was good but it wasn't nothing
special and microsoft at that time
needed
something special they didn't get that
from the ratchet and clank those are
okay games but they're not that kind of
games let's be real here they're fun
games to play with there's nothing
special about ratchet and clank games
uh
but the one thing they have with all
their games you can say that because i
mean those are opinions right these are
just our opinions i didn't even like
sunset overdrive but what even sunset
overdrive has is quality there is that
polishing quality that insomniac
continuously put out um same thing goes
for uh you know uh obsidian as well
though they do the same thing i agree
with the quality uh i will say that
insomniac has better quality than than
obsidian because i've seen it makes
great gains but sometimes they're buggy
so i do think that brings the the
quality down a little bit but quality
yeah the thing is like when i'm talking
about obsidian is like you know they're
making a game in space that's an rpg
they're making a turn-based grid space
that's an rpg they're making uh they're
they they made um
that that kind of like treasure honer
diablo type of style pillars a
fraternity i'm pretty sure that's how
that kind of game is i don't know don't
don't don't don't fat check me i've
never played that game you see the
different specters that they're making
on this they're not just making you know
sunset overdrive let's be real here they
took the foundation of sunset overdrive
and adapted it and made sp spider-man
that's how they made spider-man they
they took the experience of making
sunset overdrive adapted it and like now
let's have him sleeping across the world
instead of grinding on rails
no my phone no i was going to mention
that too because i did a video on like
insomniac and how consistent they are
and no for now for nothing man they took
you know the weapon elements and from i
think it was resistance that they made
and they implemented and then
implemented it stuff like that into
sunset overdrive and then later on
spider-man so
you know like the the praises will do
man the praise is definitely well due i
mean look i'm not no xbox head but if i
were that that's one of the studios that
you know if they ever came up for sale
but you they won't know because uh
playstation got them for 230 million but
yeah them the ones you go after for real
man them the ones that you go after
because they they've proven that they
can make a game that's kind of serious
in the game that isn't so serious um
they make the the dope
goofy games and they can make the the
more but serious games yeah
xbox though when you think about
obsidian and you think about
bethesda and all the teams they have now
under their belt they have
western rpgs on lock bro they do the
only people they're missing that make
serious western rpgs is i would say the
people that make divinity
um they're missing them uh they're
missing cd projekt regardless how you
feel about their last game they're still
very competitive
it's just i feel like they got too
ambitious for cyberpunk and stuff kept
going wrong and they eventually it got
to the point where politics took over
and they were just set out to draw to
die like
it's just like look like
regardless what's going on
it's just a good time in gaming right
now we got games coming up from everyone
i feel like you know we're going to see
god of war next year
it's going to be a good like this year
we're in march about to go into april
and it's already we've already been hit
with with eldon ring probably one of the
best games that's come out in years we
was hit with dying light too i know a
lot of people had issues but i love
dying light too triangle strategy was a
great game like there's literally been a
great game every week we got horizon
forbidden west that was that was clap by
odin ring like we got all of these
amazing experiences
that's just there that we don't normally
you know what's funny is like so i my
girlfriend she was like she's like
you're playing a lot of gangster lately
i'm like i had to assure her look
this doesn't happen all the time okay no
it doesn't it was like i was like i can
promise you usually this happens in
november but it's not to this degree
like but we got so many games within a
three-week basis it was
insane bro at the end of the year you're
gonna get games like gotham knights
um hogwarts legacy there's going to be
so many games at the end of the year
that you're it's going to be the same
situation as the beginning this month
but not only that though y'all like yo
in a couple days kirby's you know i'm
gonna say kirby's dreamland that's
that's the retro one we're talking about
the current the new the new kirby game
is coming out
and one of the games that we didn't
mention at all um you know that y'all
didn't mention right
you know teenage mutant ninja turtles
shredders revenge
be be on the lookout because i'm telling
you that that game's going to be up
there too
unless if this thing fall off a cliff
that game gonna be up there too so
there's a lot to like really look
forward to um
they said god of war was supposed to
came out this year
hey i'll be right back i'll be right
back a lot of it a lot of what god of
war it was built upon was you know older
assets anyway
the foundation was already there the
thing is with 2018 so i can't see this
game being pushed and pushed back
very much at all the reason i feel like
that is because i said it last year
sony's not the type of studio the
company anymore to release games in
november october they kind of leave that
for the other stuff and i feel like
i mean it's possible sony's changing man
sony might be
changing but until i see that change
with this particular thing i have to
assume that they're going to
[Music]
at e3 whatever their e3 thing is
they're going to show god of war with
like a february release day okay uh let
me let me tell i'll give you i'll give
you a date i think it's going to be
dropping i'll give you the exact date oh
it sounds like you know something what's
up with this no no no no i'm just
checking my calendar here i'm going to
say that this game drops october 28th
this year october 28th
god of war that is a october 28th it's a
friday all right i'm going to put in my
calendar right now
yeah if i'm right then uh yeah on my
calendar right now
where october 28th october 28th is is is
my
uh my my my guess
all right god of war we're gonna go to
october ragnarok
october
28th
i think they're gonna vote jay fawns
loses
loses
and then we'll go ahead and put yours in
february
and and see who wins that
okay so i will say
february
the 11th no the the hustle you got a
date the 10th
the day
yeah got to work give a date
whenever you think it might come out
this year next year february 10 2023
well if i had to guess um what comes off
a playstation in november this year
nothing right
if i if it does come out this year
and i had the guys i'll take a look on
my calendar as i do this it'll be their
big uh
but they don't really don't really drop
in november though bro they're gonna go
up against starfield
but they don't really drop in november
when the last time they dropped didn't
they dropping like september the last
day they usually drop early you know in
the years springtime they're big games
march right when they're march when okay
february march yeah well we ain't really
saying nothing about it but if i had to
guess if if in any way
chat chat put it i'd say november i
would say uh november 18th that's my
nephew's birthday
okay put in
the chat what day you think god of war
is coming out put 2022
or put 2023.
hustle's putting uh a breath of the wild
on on starfield he said god awards gonna
hit the week after star field drops man
ain't nobody trippin on some damn stuff
phil all right
you you saw what the last one did we so
we all saw the last uh god award then
let's not do that let's start come on
y'all but here's the thing here's the
thing uh bethesda when it comes to their
their games like this they they do
numbers because starfish that's a lot of
casual fans starfield's gonna come out
smack god of war straight to the yeah it
would smack god
oh when it comes to copies sold you're
talking steam you're talking microsoft
you're talking game pass numbers it's
going to destroy anything else
give me an exclusive
give me an exclusive
uh i don't have an excuse but i'm just
telling you from bethesda's pedigree
what we know of their games when they
drop their big games their fallouts
their elder scrolls it doesn't matter
when they drop
so many casuals play their games and
that's that's what it's about man you
hit that casual market to home run like
let's have just like
a thing that's never going to happen but
let's do it
god of war starfield come out the same
year who wins oh the same day
who wins that we're talking about those
numbers who wins that month who wins
that month starfield youtube starfield i
think god of war beats it in sales i
don't know why here's the thing
here's the thing god of war 2018 was
fresh it was something new
everybody's seen what's to come of
ragnarok and it looks like the same old
right it looks like exactly like what we
got from 2018 there's not much
difference there there's nothing really
refreshing coming with this game but
with star field you are getting
something refreshing bethesda is
creating a brand new ip for the first
time in so many years
that is the key here and and again
casuals love but thanks to rpgs look
look if star field has the kind of
caliber of eldon ring then yes it will
probably outsell it but to me
starfield is going to be interesting
star field is going to be in game pass
day and date so that's going to hurt the
the xbox sales a little bit um you know
it's going to sell very well on pc we
know they always do
i'm just skeptical
because i know
that god of war is going to be on
playstation and
and it got so much hype from the
original one uh we got a five dollar
super chat from donald taku if guardaro
ragnarok's hits like forbidden west did
aka more of the same it's not even
touching starfield i disagree it's not
it's not bro
if this was if this was god award 2018
it's different because again that
freshness does a lot for people like
that brand new
thing you know when it comes to games
that's what does something for people
starfield is that new new that's what
people want i think i'm telling you you
will agree uh fawns i i was i think we
said it last week it's like look like
i think breath of the wild 2 is going to
be an amazing game god of war ragnarok
it's going to be an amazing game but you
could only do that i'm switching [ __ ] up
one time
exactly they're not going to get that
benefit of the doubt the second time
around
yeah exactly you're going to hear a lot
of this game's amazing but it's more god
awards
exactly it's more 2018 god of war in
fact a lot of the assets look it's
exactly the same and and people
that does resonate with people it's like
how much more am i gonna get from this
game opposed to the last i have that
same feeling with horizon forbidden west
right now it's just more of horizon zero
dawn that's all it is
it may look better because of the you
know resolution and stuff but at the end
of the day a lot of the assets are
pretty the same the animations and stuff
we've seen them on twitter they've done
a side-by-side comparison they used a
lot of the same assets it's what they do
i mean this is what developers do and
the same thing for god of war
but
that freshness does play a lot into
these games when they drop down with
this look at him
it wasn't there look i i get it i do
think it won that i think you know god
war comes out this year it's gonna be a
great year i don't think uh it is uh you
know regardless gonna be phenomenal bro
don't get me wrong i think ragnarok is
going to be fun as hell i loved 2018 it
deserved to be game of the year even
though i i prefer red dead redemption 2
that year i liked it better and that was
my game of the year i still think god
award deserved it over red dead too
because of how many people it it really
in it
because it was just a better game
i don't agree but but but i i look i it
doesn't hurt me at all because i loved
god of war as well god of war was
phenomenal but i'm not going to get that
same fresh feeling from god of war yeah
this new one coming out it's the same
it's going to be this dude when you
start the wild did you play horizon
forbidden west
as you're playing it you're like this
isn't new bro this is zero dawn all over
again zero there's nothing new here
they put a grapple hook in that you
could barely use anyway it's like
like seriously like i
there's nothing really fresh about it
all right well but listen listen here
you you botched
i ain't worried about god of war and i
think it's one i'm not worried about
it's going to do numbers i think this
won't do it but it ain't going to lose
starfield numbers see see what's going
to what's going to happen hustle
is the
goku
is going to be starfilled and jared is
is is is god of war and the fight was
good but at the end of the day you know
who won that fight like
look at what elden rings done it it puts
something fresh into the series
and it's it's doing numbers and it's
doing more numbers than sony games and
and and of course it's on pace to
probably do the best numbers this year
out of any game until starfield i would
say i think starfield has a chance to be
that game to really take over in the
numbers game and and i think it's going
to sell like gangbusters this is the
first new ip from bethesda people are
clamoring for this so hard you had sony
guys fighting for this game before
saying no this is going to be exclusive
to sony
forget what they're saying now all the
negative talk they can't wait to play
this game either they can't wait
there's no way in hell that joining up
my fault my father ain't no way in hell
that's when i was selling eldon ring and
i ain't no elder ring fan as y'all know
no no that elder ring just did like 12
million in like a month oh
that's insane but no no that's not going
to happen no i i think it could because
you're talking about being sold on steam
as well i mean this game isn't just
going to be you know uh delegated to one
platform this is also going to be on pc
as well
i'm telling you bro the power
tells you
the power of bethesda compels you
the power of bethesda will compel you
and and that's just it the casual market
is king and the casual market loves
however bethesda compels you
i feel like you know i'm spraying a
little holy water my way it's not gonna
work man it's not gonna work it's not
working no it's not working a little bit
a little bit
nah
nah
we got a two dollar super chat from
splendiferous
will god have bugs on release and if so
uh what's meta i don't know what that
method what's the what's the metacritic
score
did you say 96. i sure did you you
didn't i mean you really didn't the last
of us bought one oh
it'll be lower than 2018. it it'll hit i
what did god of war 2018 hit yeah 95.
95. it'll be 91. you need to stop castle
you're killing
and again it's because of the fresh the
freshness thing that's a big factor in
these games
brand new ips always we got a [ __ ] jay
been a member for nine months what up
[ __ ] god of war is getting slapped in
the face with baby powder by starfish oh
man
i agree yeah and i love god of war we
got a two dollar super chat from gregory
allen man put put something in there man
you can always say something we got a
two dollar super chat from john to taku
but breath of the wild to smack it any
game in sight
that's your opponent might not be wrong
that's your opinion might not be wrong
we got a five dollar shooter from ladies
saying just putting it out there god
award isn't for pre-order yet this year
yet for spoken or forsaken or whatever
that game's called
in october is how you feel about it yeah
that's true
fonts yeah no we ain't heard nothing
from it in fact um as we all was we all
were talking i had saw something on
twitter somebody posted like a picture
now i don't think too much
you know i don't take too much into that
but
um
attic i will
well i'll reach with y'all follow me
until y'all see it yeah so it's just oh
you know hey we heard that yet i mean
hopefully we'll hit something that e3
and then you know hit this with a
surprise drop but something like that is
gonna do that thing well but you know
bethesda does that but something don't
really do that so that's i think i think
you're getting the next time they show
god of war which will be by e3 time
around you know june uh they're going to
talk about it and they're going to hit
you with that date and it's going to be
october 28th
all right so well i hope so we got a
five dollar spreadsheet gregory allen
god of war will sell more than starfield
because of the two
god of wars
has the larger install base i don't know
what that is no they don't
it won't
not not when it's the power but that's
the compels y'all i'm telling you bro
you got it the power of bethesda
you know what i need i need a shirt that
says the power of bethesda compels you
because it's true bro
history dictates this bro look at that
all the es uh games all the fallout
games yeah they sold like gangbusters
and and then they were game of the ward
winners you need winners you need to
have game of the year awards you need to
have someone say that and you need to
get a sound saying that like someone
funny saying that like someone with like
a an accent or something like that it
just said that the power of i'll talk to
gas i'll have gas say it or something
you can record that okay so we um
we got a two dollars per trip from
playing uh from flame i love this side
of fawn's power of bethesda
we got a two dollar super chat from dawn
to taco hustle wildland
ragnarok and 93 max which is two dollars
super super ham slow gaming do you think
xbox games
uh a uh xgp xbox game pass will have
steam sticks before uh
starfield no i don't think that
uh we have a
four
four-month
member rail saying for spoken is is
infamous 4.5
oh my god man you might be on to
something there all right we're going to
end this
whole thing real quick this is a great
show we're going to end this with one
thing because hustle almost killed me he
needs to be brought up on charges
because he almost told me you almost got
hit with manslaughter hustle oh so we're
gonna we're gonna end this with what
everyone thinks god of war ragnaros
getting in a metacritic score
go hustle
96. 96. let me oh my god
well let me go ahead and let me go ahead
and say wow
listen the story i'm not worried about
story and i ain't worried about it if
they improve on everything that was
missed up before just like the last of
us too regardless of what people may
think about it
if everything is elevated and everything
is fixed they'll have no choice but to
go up but the story is
what is the only thing that can really
change here because everything else is
the same the gameplay is the same it's
it's it's just gotta work 2018. i can
elevate the gameplay
putting in a grapple hook that they you
could barely use like horizon forbidden
west tried it didn't work bro hey i
can't so
right yes
you're damn right on my way who put no
one oh somebody put no on that chat i
shout out to y'all i feel y'all
no
you know
you're not crazy because
96 can happen i mean god of war is a
phenomenal franchise phenomenal game
but i don't think but i don't think it's
happening i think the highest it'll get
like somebody said like a 93 i think it
would be the highest but i think it's
gonna hit about 91.
and 91 is phenomenal that's a great
score but of course it's this is the
sophomore outing uh look last of us in
my opinion even though metacritic it's
totally wrong it wasn't a better game
last of us two was not the better game
last of us one kicks its ass uh in story
for sure
um but as for mechanics and gameplay yes
it had it
it was way better um
but god awards it's not really changing
up there with mechanics and gameplay
that's reasonable hustle when people hit
me with that 96 you expect that to get
up there with eldon ring
the greatness of eldon ring
listen let me say this let me say this
kratos kratos and the trey is going to
push short
gonna push thor's
they're gonna peel his cap i i had to
really watch my language because i
forgot why i was for a second they could
they they're gonna pillage cat-back yeah
i saw he pulled up on him you know he
had the house waiting for him right now
when you boot the joint back up you know
what time it is hey listen listen i'll
think i i think it's gonna do better
than the last one yo i definitely think
it's more so way more too bad hey bladex
a blade x at least the grapple hook and
halo you could actually use that all
right that's all i'm going to say
if you ever if you ever want if you ever
want to be disappointed just think that
uh god of war is getting a 96 on
metacritic so oh man
i think
i think it's gonna knock hussle
no he's a smart guy he's just wrong here
today but he's a smart guy i think it's
gonna get like
i think it's gonna get in the hot 80s
like 88 89. i don't think it's gonna
crack the 90s i really don't because i
think one of the biggest things that
made it what it was
was because it was new it was different
and i think that
reviewers aren't giving it that that out
this time i also feel like they're only
doing this is the last game there's not
going to be a trilogy there's not going
to be a third game of
scene
so to me you still have odin you have
you have uh thor
keep in mind corey barlog isn't
directing this someone else is directing
yeah someone so
i feel like you're going to have a lot
of a lot of cramming the story like
we're going to cram whatever we can that
makes sense because we're not doing a
third game like well it'll be different
it'd be different if this game if
they're having three games this game you
fight oh um that you fought thor in the
next game you fought odin you know what
i'm saying like yeah how many trolls are
we gonna fight again and again oh man oh
come on now come on
even though i had no problem with it but
that that was a recurring theme in the
first game
uh
look look
the game is going to be fun it's going
to be phenomenal it's it's got a war
2018 again
um but it doesn't just it doesn't have
that freshness man and and that is a key
factor to getting those high scores um
addicts right we we saw it it was brand
new for god of war and we're like wow
this is incredible this is where god of
war needed to go and that is why it got
that 95 that is why i got that game of
the the uh game of the year award
um starfield is going to have it in
spades elden ring has it in spades
we'll see what happens you know
but let me get these super chats so we
can get up out of here we have two
australians when difference power of
bethesda will make so many
so uh
sony oh so many ponies oh sony not so
many ponies by little man a little bit
we gotta find
get it right it's the power of bethesda
will compel you yeah we got a five
dollar super shot from lady sand fonz
isn't lying my first bethesda game will
actually be starfield based on the last
roundabout they had i love when i'm
hearing about hardcore rpgs we got a
five dollar super chat from don otaku
god or ragnarok gonna have more than
three mob
so it'll be better than the first but it
won't be afresh anymore so 91.
we got a five with me uh five dollar
superchat for our artemis or butchered
it it's cool we're moving past this
guard awards
yeah we'll get a 96 when they have thor
kill cradles with a golf club
mr goldfinder i mean hammer
and you play as thor have to get that's
wrong hey god i hate you
hey wrote him is you're a legend for
that one that that's wild boy god let me
recover no i i i i guess what it's only
santa monica learned from tony brown
thor thor's going to take off that hood
and it's going to be abby with a hammer
i mean
[Music]
she didn't deserve this but it's i don't
know man
fun since we since we all about to get
up out of here it's blessed having you
all man you got to come back sometime
man oh of course bro i love kicking in
with you guys
the good thing about us moving to
wednesday
is like fawns isn't doing another
podcast right afterwards no yes yeah so
you know uh appreciate everyone coming
through man where we talked about the
past present and future gaming i forgot
to say that at the beginning but it's
cool i said at the end uh we got fawns
here man what people can catch you at
what's going on i know we did at the
beginning but they don't matter you're
doing it now
all right fonzarelli gaming right here
on youtube um
yeah uh catch me there uh i'm doing my
podcast every sunday and uh yeah games
talk live uh go one on one with uh
community members industry folks uh
whoever i can get on the show basically
they'll say i'll come anybody with a
with a pulse all right i'll i'll take
anyone um when's hustle getting the
invite
you know i gotta get you on hustle i
gotta wanna because we're gonna have a
fun i have fun with everybody i bring i
don't matter who comes on we we have a
good time
and uh hustle is is gonna be a
phenomenal guest gotta do it hustle
let's do it man let's do it two o'clock
sundays two o'clock night of time which
is uh west coast hopefully you can do
that sometime
um
but yes uh catch me there and also uh
rdx tuesdays on dealer gaming's channel
and shout out to
what's going on with you man what do you
got cracking this week
well
i plan on streaming super mario rpg on
friday on my twitch channel right
but uh i know we got to talking about a
few other games and there's one other
game that kind of had my attention
before attic and we spoke about this
before
um
the other worlds
i think i might start that up and if i
like if i like it enough i'm gonna do a
stream i'm gonna try to stream for like
four hours right
it's rpgs i know it's gonna take some
time to pick up if i can get four hours
there
if i can get four hours in on that joint
oh look y'all keep saying it's a great
game all right cool we'll see we'll see
i'll be the judge of that i will be
judging that what's cool is uh the
companions in that game and stuff it's
it's the the the dynamic there where you
uh you pick up different companions
they're all really cool they all got
their own little
attributes and stuff and and stuff that
they do and and they bring a lot to the
table it's it's it's a fun game really
fun game
thank you lady sam for that yeah i
definitely needed a haircut i do want to
say this i will i will postpone super
mario rpg because i had something called
the super six that i was going to do but
i am and i really do want to play on the
outer worlds even if it's just the first
one and not the dlc i do want to play
that just good games
if you do like the outer worlds what i
like is when you do the expansions
like when you look bring up the quest
log they they glow in different colors
like one expansion will go like green
one expansion will go red so like it
tells you look this is what this has to
do with this expansion and this has to
do with this expansion
and what's cool is like
originally it wasn't like this but if
you if you're at the like if you're
loading to the last mission and you want
to use that character but you've you've
already went to the point with no return
and you saved there they ask you when
you load up that thing he's like look
there's new dlc updated do you want to
be reverted to
right before you did this
oh wow that's okay all right well okay
so i i saw some stuff in the chat um
shout out to everybody's idol goro i
like that name by the way he said it's a
pretty short rpg by uh by rpg standards
but what i like why they did it is
they they condensed it they made what
did they they made it count now there's
a lot of things that can improve on
there
clearly it was a very budgeted rpg but
what you can see there is they made
something like fallout in a different
way and it worked it's just now they
need that bigger budget to make it
bigger
i only have one complaint about outer
worlds and it's it's it's just one and
and it's not huge
but it's the the fact that the world is
kind of small the exploration isn't as
deep as a fallout game and i wish it was
a little bit bigger that's off i'm finna
download this joint after the pod i'm
finna download it right now actually but
yeah
i look forward to it that's a good
streaming game you should stream now i'm
gonna start a friday we'll start a
friday night assuming i'll fall asleep
another like every time friday night
jumping hustle stream friday it it see
who he picks man see what he does see
what's going on there but i appreciate
everyone for coming through here man
we'll see you next week i'm gonna look
into a couple uh guests next week uh you
know we're getting closer and closer to
the e3 stuff uh you know i do plan on
doing e3 shows uh iops doing e3 shows
too we'll probably go in the reverse
order that they that uh we go on iop
just just so people ain't really you
know repeating information and i'm gonna
make sure that whoever i bring on for
the attic show
like prediction stuff isn't going to be
on
the iop prediction stuff so i appreciate
it for coming through here we're going
to go in the